[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors jouera contre série d entre sa
loge ici il a fait un arrêt il a fait
mal aux stands à il faut l'oeil vif ap
saint georges a mis en place mais je
reste un homme très loin
sow et frau
oui
et bien avoir calé en bois bah oui bah
oui tu as perdu alors oui je vais
l'appeler et veille à ce qu'il y ait du
mal à oui mais non non non mais voilà
attendez pas ce que les gens hésitent à
temps et à nos n'avait pas la lecture
d'extraits jouer au ping pong avec des
poils du boyard mais non
il ya mes enfants qui sont venus bien
hokkaido exprès pour voir elie semoun
ducobu et toute l'équipe qui viennent
d'arriver
je les ai mis en contact avec les
acteurs ah oui un homme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou pas
[Musique]